(upbeat guitar music)
- Hey, we should start a band.
- Yes.
(upbeat electric guitar)
- Yeah!
- [Voiceover] Let's go.
- One, two, a three, four!
(loud, out of tune rock music)
♫ Are you read to rock ♫
What shall we name the band?
- Water buffalo.
- Who are you?
- Drummer, peach pit.
- No.
- Sasha, Malia and the
Barack and rollers!
- [Man in red shirt] rollers!
- This is all ridiculous, no.
Slow down my steam train.
- I quit.
You guys really suck.
(upbeat electric guitar)
- What do you think of,
are you into Nightcore?
- No.
- I'm coming in on your signal.
(light electric guitar)
- What about that chord?
- I don't like minor fifths.
(loud drumstick clashing)
- [Both] We're trying to concentrate.
- Bring out of the raw!
- Is that the chorus?
(strong bass guitar)
- I'm the lead singer, obviously.
- What?!
No, no, no, no, no.
- I write all the songs.
- Well, I write all the melody.
- But that's the least important part.
- That's a really good photo by the way.
- He's an (mumbling) to me.
(loud rock music)
- Hey, we're in a band.
- Hey, we are in a band.
(soft, light guitar)
- Hey.
I'm, uh, I'm in a band.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Do you guys need a lead singer?
(loud rock music)
- Hey (laughs) who's this?
- This is Gabby.
- I love the whole vibe
you guys have going here.
It's like so cute but I was wondering
if you guys had ever tried to sound
a bit more like the Pixies, Weezer,
Credence Clearwater Revival, Bikini kill,
Fleetwood Mac, Rihanna.
Have you tried to be like
32 percent more punk?
- That's a great idea.
- Thank you babe.
- Yeah.
- We really need to
focus on music right now.
We have a show.
-Mind if Gabby sings on the track?
(loud rock music)
- Argh!
- Can I talk to you for a sec, Chris?
(high energy rock music)
- Hey, you coming to
the show tonight, right?
It's gonna be so much fun.
I'll buy you a beer, come on.
We need six people or we're
gonna pay for all these tickets.
Mom please buy these tickets.
Grandma!
- Hey man, did you sell those tickets.
(fast paced rock music)
- [Chris] So first song--
- What the hell man?
We talked about this.
- She's filling out the sound man.
- Okay, well, I quit.
(loud clash on drums)
- I quit.
- Looks like you have a
couple of holes to fill.
(fast paced rock music)
We're gonna do things a
bit differently this time.
- Okay but what are we
gonna name the band?
- Glitterous.
- Cheese on a Sunday.
- I got an idea.
- We are Period Drama!
- One, two, three and
four and (loud drums)
(loud, fast paced rock music)
- We are...
(loud rock music)